Traductor: Florencia Bracamonte
Revisor: Elena Crescia
La infantería avanza con firmeza.
Sus elefantes ya han cruzado
la línea defensiva.
El rey intenta retroceder, pero
la caballería del enemigo lo acorrala.
Es imposible escapar.
Pero no se trata de una guerra real.
Tampoco es solamente un juego.
Durante aproximadamente
el milenio y medio de su existencia,
el ajedrez ha sido reconocido como
una herramienta de estrategia militar,
una metáfora de las relaciones humanas
y un estándar de genialidad.
Si bien los primeros registros sobre
el ajedrez se encuentran en el siglo VII,
la leyenda cuenta que los orígenes
del juego se remontan a un siglo atrás.
Se cree que cuando el príncipe más joven
del Imperio Gupta fue muerto en batalla,
su hermano ideó una forma de representar
la escena para consolar a su madre.
En un tablero ashtapada de 8x8
usado en otros pasatiempos populares
nació un nuevo juego
con dos características esenciales:
diferentes reglas
para mover distintas piezas,
y una pieza particular, la del rey,
cuyo destino determina la victoria.
El juego fue originalmente
conocido como "chaturanga",
palabra en sánscrito que
significa "de cuatro miembros".
Pero al llegar a la Persia sasánida
adquirió su actual nombre y terminología:
"chess" deriva de "shah",
que significa "rey";
y "checkmate" de "shah mat",
o "el rey está indefenso".
Tras la conquista islámica
de Persia en el siglo VII,
el ajedrez se introdujo en el mundo árabe.
Trascendió su función
de simulacro estratégico,
y luego se convirtió en una fuente
prolífica de imaginería poética.
Diplomáticos y cortesanos
empleaban términos del ajedrez
para describir el poder político.
Los califas en el poder
se volvieron ávidos jugadores.
El historiador Al-masudi
consideró que el juego era un testamento
del libre albedrío de los hombres,
en comparación con los juegos de azar.
El comercio medieval
a lo largo de la Ruta de la Seda
llevó el juego a Asia oriental
y Asia sudoriental,
donde se desarrollaron
múltiples versiones locales.
En China, las piezas se posicionaban
en las intersecciones de los cuadrados,
no dentro de ellos, como
en el juego local de estrategia "Go".
Durante el reinado
del líder mongol Tamerlán,
el tablero era de 11x10 y tenía
cuadrados seguros, llamados "ciudadelas".
Y en el shōgi japonés,
las piezas capturadas podían
ser usadas por el contrincante.
Pero fue Europa donde el ajedrez
comenzó a tomar su forma actual.
Para el año 1000 d. C., el juego
era parte de la educación de la corte.
Se empleaba el ajedrez como alegoría
de las funciones típicas
de las diferentes clases sociales,
y las piezas eran reinterpretadas
en su nuevo contexto.
Durante este periodo,
la Iglesia desconfiaba de los juegos.
Los moralistas aconsejaban
no pasar demasiado tiempo jugando.
En Francia, el ajedrez llegó a ser
prohibido durante un breve periodo.
Aun así, el juego proliferó,
y durante el siglo XV adquirió
la forma coherente que conocemos hoy.
La pieza relativamente
débil del "consejero"
fue remodelada en la poderosa
figura de la reina,
hecho inspirado, quizá, en el reciente
incremento de líderes mujeres.
Este cambio aceleró el ritmo del juego
y, a medida que otras reglas
se popularizaban,
comenzaron a aparecer tratados donde se
analizaba el inicio y el final del juego.
Así nació la teoría del ajedrez.
Con la Ilustración, el juego se trasladó
desde las cortes a las cafeterías.
Ahora se consideraba al ajedrez
como una expresión de creatividad,
que incentivaba los movimientos
arriesgados y el juego dramático.
Este estilo "romántico" alcanzó su ápice
en la Partida Inmortal de 1851,
en la que Adolf Anderssen
consiguió dar jaque mate
tras sacrificar a su reina
y a ambas torres.
Pero la aparición del estilo competitivo
hacia el final del siglo XIX
significó que el cálculo estratégico
finalmente triunfó sobre el dramatismo.
Y con el auge de
la competencia internacional,
el ajedrez adquirió
una nueva importancia geopolítica.
Durante la Guerra Fría, la Unión Soviética
destinó ingentes recursos
a desarrollar el talento en el ajedrez,
y dominó los campeonatos
durante el resto del siglo.
Pero el jugador que superaría a los rusos
no era un ciudadano de otro país
sino una computadora IBM
llamada "Deep Blue".
Las computadoras jugadoras de ajedrez
habían estado desarrollándose por décadas,
pero la victoria de Deep Blue
contra Garry Kasparov en 1997
fue la primera vez que
una máquina vencía a un campeón.
Hoy día, el software de ajedrez
es capaz de vencer de forma consistente
a los mejores jugadores humanos.
Pero al igual que el juego
que perfeccionaron,
estas máquinas son
el resultado del ingenio humano.
Y quizá ese mismo ingenio nos indique
cómo superar este aparente jaque mate.